Huff's Gomez reddish beard Pat welcome
back to another episode of infamous
second son these headphones I'm wearing
but I don't need them
we are back in oh yeah we just kill all
these things I swear to God I just kill
all this don't take selfies when I'm not
aware Eugene I wanted to thank you for
your help
found the conduits hideout and about to
go inside that's a bad idea
come on he's a conduit it doesn't even
do his own fighting how hard can it be
yeah no no really don't go in there all
right I'll call you when it's over
Oh time to go time to learn a few new
tricks okay so this is where they make
you understand hello anybody home
yeah we found their hideout hopefully
we'll get our new ability soon that'd be
awesome fun rogue economy okay how would
I imagine from the outside
what what is that whoa whoa okay okay
they suppose the fine tune somewhere
else because I didn't do that
all right shows up a new one okay I need
to go up there cool
did it look at me Mom where's the rent
one dude run my ass
Oh green smoke got it all right well I
guess it works either way it's very cool
bigger than I'd hoped
om huge well a nice having baby boy -
good
no one's invading your Dominion okay I
just want to share your powers I just
want to cuddle up with you over they you
should be proud okay I want to cuddle up
with you what is up with that guy
someday
this is what I need to go stop stop it
stop it I want me to train the neon then
I got a shoot riding down big lady just
doing anything for you okay it's being
me I'm out of here if you're just gonna
be like that no thanks
not interesting oh gosh oh gosh that was
not part of the plan we made it
alright there you go dammit
I wasn't Amanda get back in there back
in the TV why you so mean
find rogues conduit he's really into
that anime stuff huh and that beard man
stuff yeah it's fun with me yeah yeah
yeah it's all the best in your basement
what are you doing with the people
you're angels grass oh my invited guest
salvation things not solution let the
Iraqis help
I need your power need to leave me
Mich why you feel easy when you don't
have a menu to pick me up and fly me
away huh yeah the horse you can make the
platform's fall don't chase them don't
change the layout please yeah what I
thought it's lava yes yeah we gotta keep
over here that was close cinder block
that [ __ ] that's what happens I need a
smoke I need a smoke pena smoke let me
smoke
thank you sister you're the best end of
9th and [ __ ] I don't Dodge
yes so much help it's redonkulous and I
don't have a donkey collection that's
the lamest joke I ever made
that's all [ __ ] much okay we're gonna
have yourself and he became a [ __ ]
what's happening one more serious bruise
surprise I'm sorry but I don't think
need speak English I verify a little boy
or something
don't you think all right allies TV
there must be last TV here somewhere
the last evil the last of T gone and you
go can't wait you are [ __ ] this guy
up you think I'm not tired of you [ __ ]
I'm gonna get your horse making an epic
just roar well you're just delay the
inevitable
hello flame oh god yes three friends
come on I thought you were my best
friend
you like to leave here we go come on
your friends I talked to your friends
all your enemy friends are doing what
you gonna do about the end are you gonna
close me up
well too bad I'm samosas
taste it with all joy my snack reclined
eventually it's all a matter of ten
longest boss battle [ __ ] this
festival is so much longer than any
others so far in this game I want that I
want that give me that good and we got a
line a knife it's safe can we go there
oh nice why not why not
hello friend oh god he has so many
friends now I would say would suck so
hard if we doesn't die if I die
Oh God come on ah yes a fibroid yeah
always a little there's a girl is a girl
nerd Alex boy that was your team know I
was G
at school I always had to blend in to
fade into the background to disappear
but the bullies found me anyway they
always do
the only place I felt I belonged was in
Heaven's Hellfire in that game I made
the rules
I could summon angels to protect the
victims it had demons to punish the
Bulls but the real world that that I
couldn't control at first I did my best
to ignore them until that one day no
when they pushed me too far oh [ __ ] that
is awesome
that's what you get bullies it's what
you [ __ ] yeah when the DUP came they
said they were taking me to a new school
designed for people like me different
for six years she hooked me up to her
machines it made me call them out always
we're stopping before they could save me
then that crash
that was my chance to to finally really
disappear where no one could find me
hurt me when I saw them rounding up more
people who were different I knew what
she was gonna do to the lad I knew
I knew we had to stop her that was
really awesome
so the he's the third RAM prisoner then
and I don't know if there was more who
he is starting to get old sounded like
you were in trouble so I came running
you okay - I'm fine thanks man get it
done without you oh wait yeah I'm gonna
believe what I can do now do they figure
out what it is like you poor thing she's
got a kidnapper off the streets
Oh bro not kidnapper he's more like a
rest anywhere doesn't listen to me
he took suspected conduits right off the
street against their will that's
kidnapping okay don't go anywhere first
of all thank you for using the word
conduit second of all why are you being
such a dick
fine let's just agree to disagree but we
both know it's better for everyone if he
goes in a cage
oh this session time okay
corrupt Eugene what does that do break
him of his fear of bullies by showing
him how strong it really is interesting
redeem you Eugene
the rhymes help him build his courage by
working together to save a helplessly to
corrupt or to redeem that is the
question we are going to redeem that
lone badge there you go
hang out for a second got talk to you
but you're all about rule of law not
locking up people without due process
hey normally it's what I do what so just
gets thrown out the window whenever it's
convenient for you is that it just put a
red wig an old trenchcoat on you start
calling you Augustine maybe next time
cool game boy and I over there gonna
have a little conversation conduit to
conduit no normals allowed fine if you
need me be right outside okay all right
let's talk to Eugene Evan thank you for
all your help could've done it without
you oh wait I already did I was fine so
they say Eugene you me couple conduits
hit the town you show me some of your
new video tricks I show you how to pick
up some girls I rescue some of our
marked brethren I don't think so I still
feel safer in here come on man you keep
staying down here and playing angels and
demons you're never gonna play listen
man
it's your life but there is a way for us
to live out there in the real world it's
up to us to make it out it's video games
tell me not about video games
let me know okay it's making me feel
uncomfortable it's never happened before
all right we're Sol a champion but we
are going cries to next level I don't
know if they learn oh I don't know
we need to upgrade some things that's
what I know eight upgrades definitely
need to upgrade let's do it
gimmie gig ah video is my new ability a
while it's a big tree tell me check out
the new arsenal not a great start
haha forgot about that part I can't
drain Neil now I have to drain TV is
that it how did that work okay Reggie
man I need you like all of my powers are
gone I got I did nothing new from Eugene
or any of the old stuff hey oh yeah well
so my couch no it's it's too open here
GPS says there's an alley a few blocks
away
alright I got it creet you there
meet up wear your ID Oh was that a
high-five no he's taking a selfie
everyone is so self-absorbed they have
to take selfies
let's go free ride on this guy just so
we can go faster my feet are going
through its window the guy inside does
not seem to care
neither do I just want a free ride on
please make him right here
Oh for the love of God all right fine
not a good time pose where is this place
here it is
what is he doing play minigames thank
god you're here red I need your help we
slowed it did you say you lost all of
your powers yes I lost all my powers I
lost smoke
I lost neon I never even got it it is
great this is great news man the hell is
this great news I've got a thousand
dupes after me and I've got nothing to
go on remember we said we were gonna
find a cure for you and this is it I
mean all that bio terry stuff it's gone
Nelson you can go home now
yeah what about Betty oh listen you have
given it your best
all right the tribe knows that I know
that but it is a miracle you are even
still alive me please can't we just quit
while you're ahead for once tell me the
truth
if you were me would you just quit and
go home absolutely if I were you
no so I don't care if I have to throw
rocks I'm gonna get Augustine but since
I'd rather avoid the whole David and
Goliath throwing rocks scenario I really
need your help
yeah well it sounds like you've already
made up your mind so why do you need me
yes I know I'm gonna any chance of
getting any powers back it's gonna be
through one of these core relays of
course but damn it reg I can't crack one
of these things without any powers
alright so I I don't actually need you I
need your gun No
no no no no you are not getting my gun
and that is fine but maybe I will let
you have a couple of my bullets
thanks man
that's cutest thing let's drain it
constipation time
what if again I'm so excited we can
Melanie I know I'm gonna regret asking
what's new you might want to stand back
okay whoa thing I stood back well maybe
the next one will have like projectiles
are nice and kind of sashing I'll call
and let you know oh no I'm coming with
you
no no no you're not I got listen unless
you're planning to open the next core
relay with invisibility you still need
me besides you don't know where it is
all already tonight oh really what a
great brother betraying the government I
guess we got stuck with only one power
visibility isn't so bad no kid right
I've been planning what I would do if I
could turn invisible since I hit puberty
this conversation is now over and I got
an image let's go ahead and pop it open
what a great brother
what do we get what do we get it's like
Christmas like Christmas cool it's like
mr. Hankey all right so now we every
armely yeah oh I hope so because we got
a ton of DUP heading our way
oh what a good coincidence smack my
[ __ ] up
we emotionless lid so now I can subdue
them alright hey cool it
hey I say get four high cover ha ha ha
oh that's awesome
oh they can't be inside a circle oh
whoops I mean they're do that MC Reggie
alright yeah fine let's just get to the
next core relay sorry skip too dangerous
for you to keep tagging along little
buddy
alright bye Reggie nice to leave him
apparently I don't even know where are
we going okie dokie next core relay is
where hi Humber be the guy who knows
where the next core relays put you on
hold
Eugene is Delson listen your flying
friends they've probably done some
aerial recon around here right ah good
and I need you to help me find something
you know those glowing boxes the deeps
put up around town sure
haters what not far from you thanks oh
hey uh I've seen a couple of those
suspected bioterrorist still getting
harassed on the streets what do you say
get this new sword they can help them
out Oh
right I know right so you interested no
that's okay
I've got level 11 angels wait what
happened it was being assaulted suspect
oh you're welcome by the way
just walks up awkwardly how long as I'm
you might as well Pat that hmm if I can
be buffet oh my god finally Bruce is
gonna be so cool we are getting angel
wings
well don't know oh there you go cool
sweet Regina I know you'd rather be
alone with your demons but I just got
ambushed by dupes snipers you're gonna
have to pitch in here bud okay
I'm gonna use but I'll just an angel oh
thanks hi
I meant to ask about the girls the one
on the bus she okay
Oh bench yeah great
oh okay no listen man she is way ha ha
ha you gotta learn to crawl before you
can hop aboard the rocket sled ah
did that guy the one caused the crash
did you get away Hey
pink Augustine killed it really [ __ ] oh
oh don't worry you're dealing with
Augustine soon enough yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
you're like the meanest of the meanest
no I mean like how god she's some evil
she's is like he straight-up mean unless
have a few wingmen this time around
LTI can disappear stab and run exactly
great anti-aircraft strategy what a
great fish collection the colas outlet
my favorite Oh
or you can just do this hi lads you
guarding this
what do we get this time oh my god it's
so much fun do like these where you
going this is the fun part
whee oh oh my god
hey Eugene not to sound ungrateful but
you think maybe next time you could send
less powered Li demons I thought you
just wanted them to work dude you can't
just half-ass this we conduits have got
to take care of our own okay
next time I promise I found another one
good Thank You Barbara here thank you
fish you just fly like crazy
hello it oh my God look at that that's
amazing
same place you are
hey nice to hear you got your boys the
sack up this time you tell them to bring
whatever they got cuz I'm gonna need
help here okay let's see what we get
this is probably in this shoot a tank
yeah definitely just shoot a tank oh
that's like a machine gun
amazing
look at that oh you give up joy nice
smooth meiosis - Moses a lot of things
we are what go pee free [ __ ] yeah and
all but I've got matching I've located
another coral realized hose that bad
news watching be in that area but maybe
you've already got enough powers but why
take the risk we don't even know what
you'll get
hey don't you gene out on me okay we set
our minds to it there's nothing a couple
of young conduits and a buttload of
angels and demons can't accomplish no
tell you what I get there all right
where is it oh it's over here okay
Eugene here's the plan I'm gonna sneak
around to the side come on Eugene you
can do better than this you can't do it
stud you what the hell all right fellas
let's win one for the
I'm sorry did you not see this giant a
sword that I have
this should be the second-last power if
I'm correct
Nelson look I hope whatever you got was
worth it because you're gonna need it oh
yeah oh hello
Hellfire swarm oh oh my god
here comes heaven hell and Delson and
fuels thanks voices man you and the
brain not on me
uh just someone to think about heaven
hell Nelson in Eugene no no you want the
billing you got to get out of here get
your hands dirty
Wow I'm not very good with people shut
up you're great with people
dingy you're the guy you just say
shouting Eugene is the best hell if I
know man
maybe you ask the next one in person oh
thank you Jason or how about a few more
people
attaboy good night did you read it I got
some upgrades reg I'm sorry to keep you
waiting
first of all I'm glad to hear you're
still alive and second of all but
wait'll you see what I can do bad I've
got swords and I've got missiles and
demons swooping down from the sky I'm
dangerous
hi guys maybe a little bit cool thank
you
hey this hardly wait to use this on
Augustine yeah he's gonna get it but in
the next episode
alright friends thank you for watching
and hanging out with me today and thank
you as always for liking and supporting
the series it's been really awesome to
share this with you so far so pears for
a couple more now right
stay awesome bros bro